les en prennent pour leur grade je
voudrais les les remercier mais je ne
sais pas s'il nous écoutent je pense
qu'il y a pas de qui soit vraiment
[Musique]
épicurieux salut les épicurieuses et les
épicurieux aujourd'hui j'ai l'immense
plaisir d'accueillir dans l'atelier un
ami enfin plutôt deux amis Philippe
galuc et son chat bonjour Philippe
bonjour jamis ça va bien ouais je parle
à sa place hein parce que lui si on le
laisse face à lui-même c'est rien c'est
juste une feuille de papier est-ce que
le chat est devenu épicurieux parce que
la dernière fois qu'il s'est exprimé
épicurieux n'existait pas est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il est devenu épicurieux
alors je ne te demande pas la réponse
immédiate parce que c'est le chat qui va
s'exprimer et qui va s'exprimer à
travers un dessin on va attendre la fin
de notre entretien c'est une question
que je t'ai posé en préparant cet
échange et on aura la réponse à la fin
de l'entretien comment il va le chat au
bout de 40 ans bah il est égal à
lui-même toujours fascieux farceur
crétin ou philosophe je l'ai inventé un
peu par hasard pour le journal Le Soir
en mars 83 et ce 24e album est danse
parce qu'il fait 64 pages au lieu de 48
habituels et parce que 24 albums c'est
un chiffre symbolique pour moi puisque
c'est le nombre d'album de Tintin
produit par RG vous formez un un tandem
il vieillit pas non moi en revanche j'ai
pris quelques perdu quelques cheveux
mais dont j'ai fait des pinceaux pour
pour les couleurs il vieillit pas non
c'est c'est ça qui est magique avec un
personnage de fiction à chaque fois que
je te vois j'ai l'impression de parler à
deux personnes parce que parfois tu peux
dire quelque chose mais je me dis dans
sa tête comment le chat est en train
d'analyser cette situation les choses
sont très claires il y a lui et il y a
moi quand il dit une connerie c'est lui
qui s'exprime quand il dit quelque chose
d'intelligent c'est moi qui qui parle
par sa bouche ah c'est bien c'est facile
je pense que le chat peut parfois
balancer des horreurs sur des sujets
graves grinçant
et son regard qui est toujours
bienveillant pour les faibles pour ceux
qui souffrent pour les victimes il est
toujours du côté de de de cela et je
pense que les lecteurs le comprennent
bien il n'est jamais cynique il n'est
jamais odieux il n'est ou s'il est
odieux c'est pour faire rire et on sait
très bien que c'est pour faire rire mon
but mon envie c'est de surprendre par le
thème abordé par la forme que j'adopte
par la couleur ou le Noiret blanc et
surtout en me disant que quand on
l'attend sérieux il est déconnant et
quand on l'attend idiot il dit une chose
très sensé alors en revanche il y a des
thèmes qui reviennent régulièrement je
pense au taliban oui je ne les aime pas
et ça se voit oui c'est à chaque fois
ancré dans dans dans le contexte dans
l'actualité voilà qui pour certains
thèmes malheureusement comme les
violences faites au au plus faible comme
la fin dans le monde comme la pollution
comme l'intégrisme et cetera sont des
thèmes larges et qui seront encore
présents quelques années je le crain les
cons en prennent pour leur grade
beaucoup mais ça je voudrais les les
remercier mais je ne sais pas s'ils nous
écoutent je pense qu'il y a pas de con
qui soit vraiment épicurieux général en
général on ne le sait pas soi-même mais
alors si je connais des cons qui se sont
mis à à regarder à suivre etpis curieux
et tout à coup ils sont devenus des gens
formidables donc la connerie est une
maladie qui n'est pas là pour toujours
on peut la soigner merci Docteur comment
naissent tous ces dessins toutes ces
petites histoires je n'en sais rien ce
sont des idées qui P il y a une idée qui
vient alors je l'écris sur un papier ù
je la dessine tout de suite quand je
fais un dessin et que mes collaborateurs
me voient rire en dessinant ils se
disent ça ça va être un bon dessin tu
n'utilises pas l'actualité mais l'air du
temps moi il y en a une qui m'a beaucoup
fait sourire c'est celle des des des
hommes grenouilles il des plongeurs
c'est au moment euh du confinement des
masques et cetera et j'ai dessiné donc
deux hommes-grenouilles en appelant ça
l'humour chez les hommesgrenouilles et
il y en a un qui montre un petit carton
à l'autre en disant le porort du masque
est obligatoire je pense que dans les
années à venir si les confinements et
les virus genre covid ne nous emmerdent
plus les hommes grenouilles vont
continuer à porter le masque on a parlé
de de de de FACÉ c'est très caustique
aussi il y a ce ce ce dessin qui parle
de de de diabète et de caramel quand on
ininère un diabétique ça sent le caramel
bon faut faut oser quand même on peut
rire de tout oui oui je pense qu'on peut
rire de tout et j'ai quelques dessins
aussi sur le handicap j'ai fait
récemment un dessin et j'ai oublié de le
mettre dans l'album et pourtant je
l'aime bien donc il sera dans le suivant
réserve déjà le 25e album chez votre
libraire et c'est le chat qui parle à un
enfant qui est dans un fauteuil roulant
et il lui dit qu'est-ce que tu voudras
faire plus tard et le gamin lui répond
du stand up et oui et tu sais que des
personnes en fauteuil des personnes
handicapées viennent me voir lors de
séances de dédicace pour me dire
de nous inclure dans vos dessins on se
sent mieux on se sent plus faire partie
de la société alors qu'il y a tellement
de signes qui nous en excluent oui parce
que c'est drôle le chat drôle il ne se
moque pas alors dans la même veine il y
a celle aussi sur sur Kennedy à part
avoir été assassiné qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait dans sa vie oui on sait plus
hein mais il est très connu il est très
connu pour avoir été assassiné mais mais
en même temps ça en dit beaucoup de
notre société parce que tout le monde
connaî y mais demander à n'importe qui
qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait est-ce que tu as un chat mais un
vrai là en chair et en os et avec des
poils mais je te trouve très curieux toi
c'est ma vie privée ça non je n'ai pas
de Ch autre chose alors là que j'adore
c'est ton jeu avec les mots mais ce ne
sont pas forcément des jeux de mots
c'est plus subtile merci je vais envoyer
un petit mot à Victor Hugo pour lui dire
tu vois bien que le jeu de mot n'est pas
forcément la fiande de l'esprit qui vole
c'est bien absolument en revanche je
note que le chat aime faire des
démonstrations euh qu'il aime aussi la
biologie avec les différents sens qu'il
aime les mot il aime aussi
l'histoire il aime les chiffres voilà de
temps en temps il parle il parle
d'Einstein tout ça c'est très épicurieux
le chat est-il épicurieux la réponse est
oui c'est pas C question là qu'il répond
il t'en pose une autre comment fait-on
pour transformer un vilain défaut en une
immense qualité j'ai toujours entendu
dire quand j'étais mum la curiosité est
un vilain défaut et là vous nous
apportez la preuve inverse que être
curieux est une immense qualité
d'ailleurs des scientifiques l'ont
prouvé c'est que c'est la curiosité qui
a permis à l'homme d'évoluer vers ce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui la curiosité
c'est plutôt
un joli défaut merci beaucoup PhIP
d'avoir fait le chemin jusqu'ici jusque
dans l'atelier je souhaite bien
évidemment un immense succès à ce 24e
album un bon anniversaire au chat et
encore une fois je dis ce qui est génial
avec le chat c'est que on peut relire de
fois TR fois 10 fois les histoires on
rit
[Applaudissements]
toujours